Speaker 1: Let's get right into this week's
world famous mailbag if you have a message
for me. Hopefully substantive, hopefully not
containing slurs. You can email info at David
Pakman dot com and many of you do. And we
review a handful or so of a couple of handfuls
to guess depends on the size of your hand.
A handful of those emails every single week,
starting sometimes with people who don't like
me, Dakota wrote in with the subject. You're
a village idiot. Now, almost a requirement is that
you use the wrong form of yours versus you are.
And indeed, that's what Dakota does. You're a
village idiot. My a village idiot. OK, you spit
on all the graves of all the fine people who have
fought for this country and die for your lazy ass.
Anybody know what they're talking about? You piss
on the graves of all the fine people who have gave
their lives for you can say the ass and lies
you spew U. S on the lives of the family members
who have given their sons and daughters.
So you slime ball can lie like you do.
You are garbage and an effing waste of sperm.
Please go back to school and get an education,
and maybe you can get a job on CNN.
You're a loser. That's why. Oh, you are.
I think this is sort of like a presented
without comment type of scenario. Let's move
on. This one almost just as bad Jeremy wrote
in with the subject Commie idiot. This email.
You have to describe them if case people are
listening. Written in all capital letters.
Jeremy writing, Hey commie genius. If there's
global warning, why is it so cold here in Texas,
more like global cooling were sick of terror. Fake
news media and your dumb. The only media we trust
now is OANN and Newsmax. I hope you freeze to
death spelled like the great drummer Josh Freeze,
not freeze. I hope you freeze to death
with your global warming and COVID hoax.
P.S. Your gay y0u are your gay. Pips Trump won by
a landslide, he's still my president and yours to
call me, just wait until March for you and the
other commies will be arrested. The military is
taking control and Trump is in charge. Education,
critical thinking. Mental health treatment.
Media literacy. Many deficits in this country
exposed by the mailbag. All right, let's get
into more substantive, substantive stuff, Felix
wrote in saying Trump guilty of numerous felonies,
why not prosecuted? It's a fair question. Dear
David, sir, I genuinely don't understand it.
Trump seems to be guilty of numerous felonies.
Why isn't he prosecuted? Why not convicted? Why
is there obviously no interest in doing so? Are
there serious consequences for the person who
would have the power to do it? This person could
go down in the history books. Wouldn't it also
be something the Democrats could use? Well, in
the election campaign, I genuinely don't get it.
Yeah, these are. These are all fair questions. And
what we learned last week is that the prosecutors
investigating Trump in Manhattan believed
he had indeed committed multiple provable
felonies and resigned. So did Mark Pomerantz. The
prosecutor resigned because he thought it clear
that there was no actual plan to prosecute Trump.
He said, We've done the investigation. We have the
evidence the evidence is solid enough, we could
prove this stuff in court, but there's no interest
in prosecuting and as I've said before. There's
big hesitation to be the first to prosecute.
I believe if you saw one prosecution of Trump that
you would see many. And what they're afraid of?
I don't know. At the end of the day, as many
of you know, we did start publishing The David
Pakman Show clips to the right wing platform
Rumble, Langdon wrote in about Rumble and saying,
it's not so much free speech. Hey, David, when I
saw you joined Rumble, I figured I would join as
well and test their claims of being immune to
cancel culture and 100 percent free speech. As
you probably know, videos and comments are rated
by the number of rumbles received. You can read
a video or comment with a positive or a negative
rumble. So, for example, if a comment gets four
positives and negatives, your net rumble is minus
two when you get into the negative. Your comment
is automatically hidden and you are not allowed
to reply to any replies to your original comment.
This is not a shock. This is not a shock and there
is no meaningless. And we all know that they were
a free if a platform markets itself as being a
free speech platform. It's already kind of weird.
You know, when I think of platforms, I think
about their functionality and utility. YouTube,
the biggest video sharing site in the world. Oh,
it's about sharing videos. That's what it's about.
TikTok it is a rapidly growing vertical
format, short form video content. Oh, OK,
that's what it's about. When some of this is
a free speech platform, it's almost not even
really a meaningful mission or description.
And you should anytime you hear that,
you should at least be wondering what the
hell are they talking about? Let's see, Mike
wrote in about my appearance on the right wing
Michael Knowles show, saying, Dear David Pakman
coming from a conservative perspective, I heard
you on the Michael Knowles show this morning and
wanted to thank you for coming across the aisle
to have such a civil conversation about such
polarizing issues. I was extremely impressed in
the way you engaged him. I meandered over to your
side and again was quite impressed. I'm looking
forward to exploring more of your content. I hope
other Daily Wire followers are as appreciative
of your willingness to debate these topics,
something I find less and less of these days.
Best of luck. Yeah, I actually did get three
very nice emails from people who cut my Daily
Wire appearance. Here's another one. Kyle, hey,
really enjoyed your perspective while you
were on the Michael Knowles show? I don't
agree with everything, he said. I don't agree
with everything he says. But finding different
opinions were crap is not shoved down our neck
without a moment to hear a counter. Opinion is not
always easy to find. I appreciate you having the
conversation with them and keeping them honest.
I appreciated your insistence. Be heard so
I could understand your perspective better,
even if it challenged my own views. This is this
is great. This is great to see. Unfortunately, the
vast majority of the messages I got were horribly
anti-Semitic and just slurs and attacks. But
I did get three nice messages from that
appearance, Kerry wrote in Kerry says, Hey David,
love your show. My whole family watches together
every night. Miss you on weekends. Not sure if
you've covered this, but it would be interesting
to delve into the psychology behind why some
people believe in conspiracy theories. There
must be a certain personality type that has the
tendency to be drawn into conspiracy over truth
and facts. Have a great day. It is an interesting
topic. We've studied it extensively and I've done
a number of interviews. And at the end of the day,
one of the in talking with a person, you'll
sometimes learn that they don't like uncertainty
and not liking uncertainty often goes hand in hand
with being susceptible to conspiratorial thinking.
And the underlying kind of idea is
when terrible things happen seemingly
that are random. That can be really tough for
people who want to believe everything is certain.
Everything is planned. Everything is
predictable and happens for a reason.
And so it starts to become preferable
to them to believe instead of, wow,
that was a random bombing, I could have been
there or my loved ones could have been anybody
could have been there. That's crazy. Completely
unpredictable. Instead, it's more comforting in
a way to know there's not random bad stuff. That
was a planned event. It was a false flag. It was
whatever that idea or that feeling is
common to a lot of conspiratorial thinking,
not all. And there's much more to it. But that. Is
something we've explored and very much worthwhile.
Last one today is from Judy, I'm sorry, it's from
Joseph, and it's about the curtain Angie Brown
Jackson hearings, and it makes no sense.
The subject line is Judy demeaning yourself.
I don't know what that means. Anyway, it says,
David, when you just lie and act like justices,
Barrett and Kavanaugh were not qualified
for the Supreme Court based on their resume.
You just demean yourself. Both were highly
qualified, just as Katon G. Brown Jackson is
when you feel the need to lie and ignore reality.
You undermine everything you say. I never said.
Barrett and Kavanaugh were unqualified, what
I said were two things, and this is where
please react to the things I say, not the
things you heard or want me to have said.
What I pointed out was if you look at her
experience across eight different areas of
law and judging, Judge Jackson is more qualified
than all nine currently on the court. That's one
thing I said, and I believe that that's true. If
you look at her experience not only as a federal
judge but on a sentencing commission and you
look at all those things, she is more types
of experience than any of the nine currently
on the court do. In addition, I said the idea
that Kavanaugh and Barrett could be qualified
and Jackson isn't is laughable. So I never said
Kavanaugh wasn't qualified. I never said Barrett
wasn't qualified. What I said is it's cartoony to
suggest Kavanaugh and Barrett might be qualified.
But Jackson is not. That doesn't make any sense.
So Joseph critical listening. Critical listening,
very, very important skill to learn. So we used
to call it active listening in school. Let's learn
it. We have a great bonus show for you today. Sign
up at Join Packman dot com to get access. We will
be a little bit of a different schedule going on
next week, but I will tell you about it soon.
Unidentified: But don't miss today's bonus.